أهلاً وسهلاً، ومرحباً بكم مجدداً في سلسلة دورة Variational Quantum Eigensolver.
اسمي Victoria Lipinska، وفي هذا الفيديو سنتعمق في كيفية تمثيل
مسألة VQE معينة بطريقة يفهمها الحاسوب الكمي.
عادةً، تُعبَّر مسألة الكيمياء الكمية من حيث طاقات
النظام.
نسمي المؤثر الذي يصف هذه الطاقات بـ الهاميلتوني.
أولاً، نحتاج إلى تكميمه.
أي التعبير عنه بلغة الكيمياء الكمية،
وهو ما يُسمى رسمياً بالتكميم الثاني.
إذا كان الهاميلتوني يصف تفاعلات الفيرميونات، مثلاً
طاقة الإلكترونات في المدارات الدورانية، فنسمي هذا
الهاميلتوني الفيرمي، وهذه ستكون نقطة انطلاقنا اليوم.
لكن الـ qubits لها لغتها الخاصة.
المؤثرات في عالم الـ qubit تُوصف بمؤثرات Pauli.
لذا تركيزنا هنا هو التعبير عن المؤثرات الفيرمية
من خلال مؤثرات الـ qubit.
يوجد تطابق مباشر واحد لواحد بين
حالتي الصفر والواحد في الفيرميونات والـ qubits.
لذا التحويل بين الحالات سهل وواضح أيضاً.
لكن تحويل المؤثرات أكثر تعقيداً بقليل.
فالهاميلتونيات الفيرمية تُعبَّر بمؤثرات الإنشاء و
الإفناء.
لذا مهمتنا هي تسهيل فهم الحاسوب الكمي
للهاميلتوني.
سنستخدم أدوات رياضية لتحويل الهاميلتوني الفيرمي
إلى هاميلتوني qubit بالـ gates.
بمعنى آخر، سنترجم بين
لغة الكيمياء الكمية ولغة الحوسبة الكمية.
تخيل سلسلتين، واحدة من الفيرميونات،
أي لغة الكيمياء الكمية.
وأخرى من الـ qubits، أي لغة الحوسبة الكمية.
للوهلة الأولى، يبدو التحويل بسيطاً، صح؟
في كلتا الحالتين، نرى أنظمة ذات مستويين.
في الفيرميونات، إما فيرميون واحد في الحالة
أو لا يوجد فيرميون على الإطلاق.
وللـ qubits، إما الحالة 0 أو الحالة 1.
لكن الأمر أدق من ذلك.
الفرق بين سلسلة qubits وسلسلة فيرميونات
هو شيء أساسي جداً في الفيزياء: ما نسميه تناظر التبادل.
فيرميونان لا يمكنهما أبداً احتلال نفس الحالة.
لكن في سلسلة الـ qubits، الأمر مختلف تماماً.
يمكن لـ qubit-ين أن يكونا في نفس الحالة،
لأن الـ qubit ليس فيرمياً.
يجب الآن إيجاد طريقة للترجمة بين السلسلتين.
في عام 1928 بالفعل، أثبت باحثان، Jordan و Wigner،
أن المؤثرات الفيرمية للسلسلة كاملةً
يمكن تمثيلها بدقة من خلال مؤثرات الـ qubit.
هذا التحويل هو الأكثر مباشرةً للحاسوب الكمي.
مثلاً، يمكن استخدامه لتحويل إشغال
مدار إلى دوران qubit واحد.
عملياً، هذا التحويل للهاميلتوني ينتج مجموعاً موزوناً من مؤثرات Pauli.
هذه حقيقة مهمة جداً، وأريدك أن تتذكرها،
وسنعود إليها في الوحدة التالية حيث سنتحدث
عن كيفية تنفيذ الـ variational circuits على الحاسوب الكمي.
التحويل أعلاه يعني أنه لو كان لدينا مثلاً
14 مؤثراً فيرمياً، سنحوّل المسألة إلى 14 qubit.
لحسن الحظ، توجد طرق ذكية لتقليل عدد الـ qubits
واستخدام موارد كمية أقل للحصول على أداء أفضل من الحاسوب الكمي.
عادةً في الأنظمة الجزيئية، سنعرف
بعض التناظرات الفيزيائية للهاميلتوني،
مثلاً، العدد الكلي للإلكترونات ثابت.
يمكن استخدام هذه المعلومة لتقليل حجم المسألة
دون فقدان أي معلومة ذات صلة.
نسمي هذه التقنية تقليص الفضاء النشط.
هذا يتيح تقليص عدد الموارد، أي عدد الـ qubits،
قبل تحويل الـ qubit مثل تحويل Jordan-Wigner.
هذه الخطوة تحسب هاميلتونياً فعالاً
وتتيح لنا استخدام qubits أقل نتيجةً لذلك.
في مثالنا مع 14 مداراً،
هذه التقنية تقلص عدد الـ qubits إلى ستة فقط.
يمكننا الآن المضي أبعد في هذه التقليصات.
يمكننا استخدام تحويلات مختلفة،
أكثر تعقيداً قليلاً من Jordan-Wigner.
أكثر الأمثلة شيوعاً هو تحويل التكافؤ.
تحويل التكافؤ لا يحوّل إشغال المدارات على الـ qubits،
بل يحوّل تكافؤ المدارات إلى qubits فردية.
لن ندخل في التفاصيل الرياضية هنا،
لكن المهم معرفته هو أن هذا التحويل يحتوي على
تكرارات إضافية يمكن استغلالها لإزالة qubit-ين إضافيين.
لذا مثالنا مع 14 مداراً، يتقلص من 14 qubit
إلى 6 qubits مع تقليص الفضاء النشط ثم إلى 4 qubits
مع تقليص الـ qubit-ين في تحويل التكافؤ.
دعونا نذكر بإيجاز تحويلاً آخر.
تحويل شائع آخر بين الفيرمي
وتمثيل الـ qubit هو تحويل Bravyi-Kitaev.
تحويل Bravyi-Kitaev يستخدم الـ qubits لتشفير المعلومات
عن كل من رقم الإشغال وتكافؤ الحالة الكمية.
تحويل Bravyi-Kitaev يجمع معلومات رقم الإشغال والتكافؤ
لأساس المدار الجزيئي بحجم N،
يُستخدم مجدداً N qubit.
لكن المعلومات المخزنة داخل كل qubit
تتفاوت الآن بحسب أي qubit هو.
أي حين يكون مؤشر الـ qubit زوجياً،
يخزّن رقم إشغال المدار المقابل
كما في تحويل Jordan-Wigner.
وحين يكون مؤشر الـ qubit فردياً، يخزّن الـ qubit تكافؤ
مجموعة معينة من أرقام الإشغال. تحويل Bravyi-Kitaev هو الأكثر كفاءةً
حين يقترب عدد الـ qubits من قوة اثنين.
تحويل Bravyi-Kitaev يجمع مزايا Jordan-Wigner
وتحويلات التكافؤ.
يقلل عدد الـ qubits التي يؤثر عليها كل حد هاميلتوني،
وهذا مهم للمحاكاة الكمية إذ إن الحدود
التي تؤثر على عدد كبير من الـ qubits في الهاميلتوني
تتطلب circuits أطول لمحاكاتها.
هذا يعني أن عمق الـ circuit
يتقلص مع تحويل Bravyi-Kitaev وبشكل عام
يمكننا الحصول على نتائج أفضل مع الأجهزة.
هذا يُعدّ تحسيناً على تحويل Jordan-Wigner
الذي ينتج هاميلتوني qubit من مرتبة N.
إذن، في هذا الفيديو استكشفنا طرقاً لتحويل
الهاميلتوني الفيرمي إلى هاميلتوني qubit.
في الفيديو التالي سنرى كيف نختار الحالة بشكل أفضل
والشكل التغايري أو الـ circuit.
نشوفكم هناك.